[Musik]
die Brote von Subway schmeckt für
Sebastian alle gleich ich würde sagen es
ist
ein Mehl Exemplar in extraweich ich will
es auch gar nicht mehr Brot nennen
zusammen mit einem Bäcker findet er
heraus dass in honey out Sesam Chi
soegano und Co überall das Gleiche drin
steckt
Wahnsinn oder so viele verschiedene
Brotsorten Sesam Parmesan Oregano hier
sind noch mal so ein bisschen und
Sonnenblumenkerne drauf und gerade hier
das Brot wird er jeden Tag frisch
gebacken wie schaffen die das das zeige
ich Ihnen jetzt
in der Düsseldorfer Innenstadt liegt die
Bulle Bäckerei von Bäckermeister Michael
gauert
hier holt sich Sebastian legehilfe er
will subway-brote nachbacken
[Musik]
ich habe dir das meistverkaufteste Brot
der Welt mitgebracht da bin ich gespannt
Michael gauert ist seit 15 Jahren
Bäckermeister er backt alle Brote von
Hand für die traditionelle Herstellung
braucht er hochwertige Zutaten und jede
Menge Zeit der Teig für sein Baguette
muss 24 Stunden lang ruhen für Subway
wäre das viel zu aufwendig die verkaufen
das meiste Brot der Welt die sind in
jedem Land vertreten es schmeckt überall
gleich
ist schon Wahnsinn eigentlich ne wenn
man sagt das ist die Definition vom Brot
auf der Welt
Subway gilt als die zweitgrößte
Restaurantkette der Welt in allen
Ländern verkaufen sie ihr
standardisiertes Brot Sebastian lege hat
vier beliebte Brotsorten von Subway
dabei Italian Parmesan Oregano Sesam und
hanniboot
die beiden Experten probieren das Innere
von allen vier Broten und staunen
[Musik]
aber krass
ohne die Kruste schmeckt das Brot immer
gleich
achso von jedem Baguette
ich nehme mal das ganz normale
[Musik]
[Applaus]
von dir
[Musik]
Standard
[Gelächter]
140 das ist nicht abgeht ist alles oder
das Sandwichbrot wiegt nicht einmal die
Hälfte ihm fehlt auch eine kräftige
Kruste
ich würde sagen es ist
ein Mehl Exemplar in extra weich ich
will es auch gar nicht mehr Brot nennen
Sebastian lege kennt die Tricks der
Industrie und ahnt welche Zutaten im
Backwaren dieser Art landen
[Musik]
die meisten Zutaten kenne ich nicht mehr
also sehe ich heute zum ersten Mal
ja verrückt
die Backen davon Millionen am Tag
Millionen am Tag
Subway verkauft Brot aus Weizenmehl
Sebastian lege fügt Enzyme Binde und
Backtriebmittel hinzu
die Zusätze lassen das Brot stark
aufgehen es wird leicht und feinporig
jetzt Menge ich einmal kurz die
trockenzutaten durch damit die damit die
Verteilung gut passt Subway setzt in
seinen Broten viel Zucker ein so viel
das 2020 ein irisches Gericht festlegt
die Sandwiches sind kein Brot sondern
eine Süßigkeit das Gebäck enthält
fünfmal so viel Zucker wie in Irland für
Brot erlaubt ist Wasser Sojaöl und
Palmfett sorgen für Saftigkeit
so das ganze lassen wir jetzt noch ein
bisschen kneten
dann fahren wir uns beiseite fertig ne
mit einem ähnlichen Teig wie diesem
versorgt Subway 644 Filialen in
Deutschland jeden Tag Alter ich habe
gleich das ganze Brot optimiert das wird
richtig gut du machst mich fertig mit
deinen Mittelchen
[Musik]
das sind auch vielleicht auch gar nicht
die Mittelchen die Subway verwendet weil
die machen das gar nicht transparent
es ist nirgendwo zu finden was in ihrem
Boot steckt
Subway gibt für sein Brot nur
Zusatzstoffe und Allergene an die
Zutaten verschweigt das Unternehmen der
Grundteig ist fertig ganz ohne Ruhezeit
und warten Sebastian lege macht daraus
jetzt drei neue Sorten das dunkle Subway
Brot besteht zu 90% aus Vollkorn
ich habe hier
Parmesan Oregano Sesam und einmal plane
mit Gerstenmalz und Honig färbt die
Industrie den Vollkornteig dunkler so
sieht er richtig gesund aus
bei den restlichen Broten macht es sich
die Industrien noch einfacher mit
einigen Körnern und Gewürzen erschafft
Sebastian lege schnell neue Brotsorten
der Teig selber bleibt bei allen hellen
Broten gleich
[Musik]
so bei Haferflocken für Kollegen
Vollkorn
hier machen wir jetzt zwei Sesam
und jetzt haben wir hier noch Parmesan
Oregano so einfach
[Gelächter]
vier verschiedene Brote das eine haben
wir noch ein bisschen angemalt das muss
ein bisschen aufgehen das machen die im
Store ja auch dann wird gebacken belegt
und richtig Geld verdient in die
subway-restaurants werden teigrohlinge
geliefert gekühlt halten sie lange
Feuchtigkeit und bleiben frisch in der
Filiale wird morgen vorbereitet und den
Tag über aufgebacken
und
yes raus
[Musik]
also Bombe aus ey guck mal oder
ich meine jetzt nicht so gleichmäßig
über Subway aber es ist schlecht nicht
schlecht komm ab zum Tisch
[Musik]
die vielen Zusatzstoffe haben ihre
Arbeit getan Sebastian lege hat vier
verschiedene Brote gezaubert
dank Triebmittel sind sie schön
aufgegangen
das lohnt sich für den Sandwich Giganten
doppelt durch die luftige Konsistenz
wirken sie groß und sind weich zu kauen
[Musik]
gemacht schon erschreckend oder
aber du sagst ja es schmeckt
und genau das ist es Subway gibt ihr
Brotrezept nicht Preis jetzt wissen wir
warum
Rheinufer in Düsseldorf Sebastian lege
möchte die subway-brote von Passanten
bewerten lassen Hallo
Leute du bist
Sebastian lege bittet zur
Blindverkostung wonach schmecken drei
verschiedene Subway Brote
zunächst die Variante Parmesan Oregano
[Musik]
fluffiges Brot ja der schmeckt noch
Weizen
das schmeckt ein bisschen
tomatisch
und ein bisschen so nach irgendwelchen
Kräutern aber ich muss das nicht
aufessen oder nein gar nicht
Parmesan Oregano erinnert die Tester an
Tomaten und Kräuter
[Musik]
Subway nennt das nächste Brot Italian
die Variante ganz ohne Körner und ohne
Kräuter
[Musik]
Brot
alle Passanten schmecken den Unterschied
Nummer drei trägt Sesamkörner auf der
Oberfläche
also sind irgendwelche Körner im Spiel
okay sehr dunkleres Brot aber jetzt
nicht ganz so das ist hell das wie
Toastbrot
auf jeden Fall irgendwie was
kornspitzenmäßiges
vom Geschmack her ist es halt so ein
bisschen mehr okay das Sesam Brot
erscheintlich als kräftiges Vollkornbrot
kennst du diese Brote Subway
alle Befragten schmecken drei
verschiedene Brote Kräuter puratoast
Körnerbrot das ist wichtig für Subway
die Kette wird mit seiner großen
Vielfalt an Brotsorten
das subway-brot gleicher Teig minimale
Unterschiede
so wird eine scheinbare Auswahl
vorgespielt
eingesetzte Zusatzstoffe gibt der
Konzern nicht Preis das kritisiert der
Verbraucherschutz
bei großen Ketten die sehr
standardisierte Rezepte haben wäre es
auch sehr einfach die Zutatenlisten ins
Internet zu stellen damit alle
Verbraucher nachschauen können